ok we'll wrote in saying what's the
stupidest question someone has asked you
this reminded me of the whole there's no
stupid questions thing that you
sometimes hear in school or you'll
sometimes hear instructors in different
fields always say listen there's no
stupid questions here any question you
ask is because you are lacking knowledge
in something and you want to know and
and there's no such thing as stupid
questions I agree that we should never
shame people for asking questions
because a question is someone seeking
knowledge as a general principle however
there are ignorant or uninformed
questions where we might hear from a uh
I don't know you might hear from a 30
year old who has lived in Western
society who has just killed someone and
they say hey is it is it illegal to go
out and kill people I mean no it's not a
stupid question but it's clearly
indicative of someone who's completely
uninformed and ignorant to basic laws
that most everybody in Western society
would sort of be aware of so I am into
the idea of not shaming anyone who is
seeking knowledge but I am NOT against
identifying questions as either
uninformed ignorant or also having sort
of purposes that are deliberately meant
to uh influence opinion right and we've
with this this leads us to leading
questions and the way polling is
sometimes done okay so I've gotten that
out of the way the stupidest question
someone has asked you I don't know that
I have completely specific examples of
quote stupid questions there are
questions that I very often find myself
answering which are really really
annoying and one of them and I've told
the story before is when people ask me
about what I do as I oh I host a
national TV and radio show they say oh
where does it air and I say well it's on
two hundred radio and TV stations as
well as on directv it has a podcast and
YouTube and then they say also with like
an online only thing and then I usually
just repeat the answer x per batim I say
no it's on two hundred radio and TV
stations and at right I find that to be
a very irritating question is it stupid
I guess not and people have written to
me when I explain this saying any time
you mention
podcast in YouTube people are just going
to assume that it's online only and that
it doesn't have like a terrestrial
presence or something like that sits
generally people defend that question
when I tell the story so for me it's not
so much about stupid questions but about
uh questions where I feel like someone's
just not listening or someone's just not
getting it I'd say it's mostly highly
annoying to me that same thing is
someone stating the obvious is kind of
the same thing as a stupid question
asking some that's too obvious is just
you know just annoying to me that's all
it is really it's not you know everyone
should try to seek knowledge and the
things they don't know to not be
ignorant on the facts at the same time
like wise you know is a sky blue today
all the weather that's nice you know I
mean these are things we all talk about
the same time some point they get to
like the the annoyance level for me
another example would be when we
announced that producer Louis was going
to be leaving the show a whole bunch of
the comments to that YouTube video were
people lamenting that I was leaving the
show and asking me why I was leaving the
show why is David leaving the show is
that a stupid question I don't know it's
certainly one that is remaining
completely completely ignorant of what
was actually said in our announcement uh
but anyway you know to answer wills
question my general principle is I don't
want to ever make someone feel bad
because they are coming to me with an
inquiry of some kind that I think really
is the principle that I adhere to when
it comes to an attitude of pro learning
and seeking knowledge etcetera but
there's no doubt that I've suffered
through any number of absolutely
annoying ignorant and very very
uninformed question including many
questions about when people learned that
i'm from argentina uh oh do you speak
portuguese know and i know that the
question is asked because they believe
that the language spoken in argentina is
Portuguese and sometimes just for kicks
I'll say no i don't i never learned it
and never explained that the reason i
didn't learn it because that's not the
language actually spoken in Argentina or
when people say oh uh do you celebrate
Christmas and I say no actually I grew
up
Jewish and I'm really pretty secular
they say oh well but I thought Jews
celebrated Christmas now don't they I
don't know where you heard that I don't
know what to tell you I'm sorry no my
answer is just no I don't know anything
about that I was once told you try to
think like a fool then you're thinking
like a fool yeah I don't know but what
and I'm not totally sure what that one
means but it sounds like a very good
piece of advice so the idea is that you
try to actually figure out what a fool
is thinking then you're actually in the
mindset of a fool that's nothing to
think about I guess yeah i will i'm
gonna have to think on that one for a
while cuz i think that's deeper than it
sounds keep the questions coming thank
you too will Bernie and Nick we will
always answer three questions for you on
friday afternoon and uh it hopefully
were imparting some knowledge and in
insight into our psyches by answering
these questions we have a terrific
terrific bonus show coming up for you
today remember david pakman.com slash
membership is the one place to say